I'm Elizabeth Olsen and I'm here with
BuzzFeed
and I'm going to play with puppies
[Music]
[Laughter]
um I don't have a dog
this okay
[Music]
there's a lot of trying oh this is
actually harder than I thought there's
um trying to figure out like how much of
uh meat do I want to bring and how much
do I want to stay true to a character
because it's not like I'm playing O.J
Simpson you know I'm not playing an
iconic character in history I'm just
playing a woman who this story has been
told
so I'm just I think it was a balance of
that
I did there's only one interview or
anything that my the woman I played
Candy Montgomery she only participated
in one
oh they're just jumping through the
piece of paper and escaping she only
participated in one interview
and it was for this book evidence of
love so I used that as my Bible was this
book because other than that she chose
not to ever do an interview after the
trial and so I respect
okay
sorry
this is so funny I'd really just we had
a really fun cast it was a lot of fun to
spend time with each other so I guess my
favorite memories were us kind of
getting to know each other when we were
filming all the church scenes when we
first started shooting
I loved filming in Austin it's a very
convenient city to live in which is
important when you relocate for seven
months but we've seen every small town
that um is within an hour's Drive
outside of Austin and there's a lot of
very few times it just feels like
genitals on my ankle sorry
[Music]
yeah I think the outfit she chooses to
wear when she's going to that's so cute
they're they're just teething on my shoe
I think it's one of the oddest outfits
that she chose to wear with what she
wore to the police station for the first
time she really dressed up and I and we
never really see her in Black in the
episode and it's the first time we can
see her dressed in black to go to the
police station and I thought that's kind
of odd and funny my least favorite
outfit I can say is the murder outfit
because I had to be in it for so long
and I got so sick of it
yeah I mean I've had worse blood
you know I've had a lot of other weird
stuff happening to me on camera then
that I'm just always wet and covered in
blood and everything I do I think oh
here he goes That's it he discovered how
to step up on those blocks oh you will
never forget it now and they're all
gonna learn at the same time
it's like watching lemmings
they're all just gonna start walking off
the cliff
[Music]
this was a very easy thing to create a
playlist for because David E Kelly had
already chosen basically for the most
part all of the music and um I really
didn't like this go before Oh nailed me
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay
now I like disco that's all I'm trying
to say
[Music]
yeah I've taken some things this I took
a piece of art we had a really amazing
production designer we had a little bit
of a sale at the end of our show and I
thought oh I took a piece of art from
one of the Gore's bathrooms
[Music]
right now is first year I am growing
from seed so it is so thrilling this is
dangerous for my fingers since we've had
a lot of rain it's been really magical
so I'm growing some peas and some fava
beans my blueberries are fat and green
and growing a lot of wildflowers oh hi
welcome back
there you go oh it doesn't care anyone
care there you go peas Babas what else
have I got going on we've got some beets
in the ground and some shallots and
potatoes goodbye and that's about it
so many memories from that that were
some of the craziest filming experiences
I've ever had but I guess the best thing
that came out of it was just being a
little call of your friend
quite a lady I would love to work with
Aubry again
[Music]
I think my favorite was us being an
agathized little dungeon Catherine and I
had to really invent some stuff there
and it was a pretty beautiful set so I
think that just anything like hanging on
a wire being tortured by her was my
favorite part of that episode
[Music]
yeah I think that I think the um
oh see there's the hall
ah we got a good sound now and now I got
your attention you don't need me now
yes the magic show he was fabulous in
that and I just really got to watch him
be great
and you know to be a little show girl
I liked what I got to wear the Oscars I
felt very very pretty in that dress
loved it I really I never done anything
like that before so it was nice doing it
with someone I know and love
[Music]
I don't know if I missed playing her but
I thought a lot of the writing was
really fun it for an actor I kind of
like playing something that doesn't feel
like a version of myself and Lee felt
like too much of a version of myself so
I'm kind of okay not saying goodbye to
her
my husband was already writing
children's books and we had oh you like
the outside of my shirt I see you're a
boy or not you know either way uh hey
you get over here
that's how my dad would parent dogs
that's what I learned hey you get over
yours if everyone speaks English
my husband was writing books and it was
during covet that he and I started
collaborating and an editor who liked
his writing for a different book asked
him to come up with an idea for um the
book about that helped children with
their anxieties my husband within like
30 minutes came up with Hattie Harmony
because he's he's got a lot of good
ideas he's like more of the cute writer
and I'm more the like facts and
structure so it's really it's actually
pretty easy for us because we complement
each other pretty well and it's I don't
recommend it for everyone I don't
recommend working with your
um significant other but it works out
for us
say rap
oh who's Wanda gonna rap with uh I guess
the new girl I really think is funny
Miss Marvel yeah I think she's very very
cute and endearing and enjoyable and so
I would say her
I watch succession and I watch SNL and I
watch the Dodgers and the Dodger season
just started so that's my current season
I'm obsessed with
I would like to go back and do something
where I could be funnier but it was it
was nice to be there oh
get that on camera my favorites just
having diarrhea everywhere
[Music]
I was shocked the moment they told me
what it was about I was shocked at the
moment they said you're the villain
no one told me until right before we
shot it so that was shocking hi you want
this there you go you want to join us
now
no but I think my goal is to make sure
that nothing seemed like a repeated Arc
I try really hard not to make it
repetitive because I think that might
not be fun for fans you guys want a pina
colada
my friend named Charlie damsky because
for some reason he likes to FaceTime a
lot and he like will FaceTime me at
eight in the morning on a Thursday and I
never understand why but he would answer
he's a very talented man though he would
answer my husband not so much he'd be
like call next time I'm not FaceTiming
you ever
I like sketch comedy shows oh we got
another
[Music]
candy shockingly enough I felt like I
could do no wrong playing her felt very
free in my body David E Kelly asking for
itself by Southwest if I missed her
because he knew I did and I said yes and
we both wish it were a fictional story
so we could do a second season
is it obvious I'm not a dog person well
that was me playing with puppies on
BuzzFeed go watch Love and Death you can
find any of these puppies you met today
on North Shore Animal League America
they all need homes and they're very
Charming
ow
[Music]